[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend die wichtigsten Nachrichten
vom Sport später wieder mit dir chr wer
gegen wen in der Champions League guten
Abend ja kaum geeinigt liegt die Ampel
schon wieder überkreuz hier sind unsere
Themen der sparkompromiss der Ampel
wackelt Landwirte protestieren gegen
geplante
Subventionskürzungen und auch innerhalb
der Koalition sind einzelne Maßnahmen
heftig
umstritten militärische Unterstützung
für litun die Bundeswehr stationiert bis
2027 erstmals dauerhaft eine Brigade in
einem NATO
Partnerland und marode Brücken im ganzen
Land auf der A66 in Hessen wird ein
wichtiger Abschnitt freigegeben tausende
Brücken müssen aber noch modernisiert
werden
[Musik]
nach dem Durchbruch im Haushaltsstreit
vor 5 Tagen ist es mit der
vorweihnachtlichen ampeleinigkeit schon
wieder vorbei die FDP etwa stellt die
Kürzungen der agrarhilfen inzwischen in
Frage der Regierungssprecher erwidert
die Beschlüsse stünden Betroffene
Landwirte trugen ihre Wut heute
jedenfalls in Protestform nach Berlin
und darum geht es konkret
landwirtschaftliche Fahrzeuge sind
bislang von der Kfz-Steuer befreit und
zum Agrardiesel gibt es Zuschüsse beides
soll jetzt wegfallen laut Bauernverband
würden der Branche so eine Milliarde
Euro pro Jahr entzogen kritik kommt auch
vom grünen Landwirtschaftsminister
östemir Carsten Berend
dazu Traktoren und schwere Landmaschinen
vor dem Brandenburger Tor genau für
diese Fahrzeuge sollen
Steuervergünstigungen und
dieselsubventionen wegfallen so der Plan
der Bundesregierung für jeden Hof eine
Mehrbelastung von mehreren Taus Euro pro
Jahr klagen die Landwirte hier das macht
in der Summe eine Milliarde Euro
jährlich die die Bauern stemmen sollen
und das ist einfach untragbar wir sind
im Moment glaube ich bei dem Paket
diejenigen die am meisten darunter
leiden und wir haben vielleicht auch zu
lange zu still gehalten tausende Bauern
aus ganz Deutschland sind dem Aufruf des
Bauernverbands gefolgt ihr
Verbandspräsident bezeichnet die
Sparpläne der Regierung als Kampfansage
an die Landwirtschaft wenn die
Bundesregierung diese unz en Vorschläge
nicht zurücknimmt werden wir ab 8 Januar
dafür sorgen egal ob es Winter ist oder
nicht dass es einen heißen einen sehr
heißen Januar geben wird
Landwirtschaftsminister östemier stellt
sich dem Protest und gegen seine
Regierungskollegen er halte nichts von
den geplanten Streichungen sagt der
Minister unter Pfiffen und
buufen alle müssen ihren Beitrag zur
Konsolidierung leisten aber es musst
Beitrag sein der geschultert werden kann
der nicht überfordert und der den Weg
nach vorne nicht blockiert konkrete
sparalternativen kamen nicht vom
Minister so verlassen die Bauern Berlin
mit großem Unmut über die
Bundesregierung ja großer Unmut nicht
nur bei den Landwirten übergestrichene
Steuererleichterungen auch der abrupte
förderstoppp für E-Autos sorgt für
großen Frust und zu alldem gibt's
innerhalb der Ampel sogar erste Stimmen
die die Pendlerpauschale nächstes Jahr
anheben wollen über das Hin und Her der
Ampel und die Reaktionen Patrizia
Wiedemeier regierungssprecher Steffen
Hebestreit ist nicht zu beneiden in
diesen Zeiten mit dieser Koalition der
mühsam ausgehandelte Kompromiss im
Haushaltsstreit noch keine Woche alt und
schon Stellen Vertreter aller drei
ampelparteien vieles wieder in Frage ihm
bleibt da nur zu beschwichtigen die
allgemeine Einigung und auch D die
grundsätzliche Stoßrichtung bleiben und
jetzt muss man in den einzelnen
Maßnahmen sehen äh aber aber da sehe ich
jetzt wenig
änderungswillen innerhalb der
Bundesregierung was Hebestreit nicht
sehen will sehen andere schon die
Diskussion um das abrupte aus für die
staatliche Förderung für den Kauf von
E-Autos hat gerade erst begonnen Kritik
daran von der SPD Grüne und FDP wollen
erneut reden über den
Agrardiesel die SPD fordert zudem eine
höhere einkommenenssteuer für Reiche und
eine Ausweitung der Pendlerpauschale als
Ausgleich für die höhere CO2 Abgabe sind
mehrbastung den Pendlerin und Pendler
gerade im ländlichen Raum nicht aus dem
Weg gehen können und deswegen ist hier
ein Ausgleich aus unserer Sicht
angezeigt von der FDP wollte sich vor
der Kamera heute keiner äußern die
Grünen versuchen zu beschwichtigen am
Ende des Tages es bleibt im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes leider kein Auge
trocken alle haben
Grund traurig zu gucken und deshalb sage
ich mal nicht noch wilde neue Vorschläge
macht das hilft niemandem weiter wir
müssen jetzt in Ruhe gucken wo wo gibt's
Geld wo kann man umverteilen vielleicht
bräuchte es aber auch ein Machtwort des
Kanzlers um all diese Diskussionen im
Keime zu ersticken doch Olaf Scholz hat
Corona und arbeitet alleine in seinem
Büro wir gehen nach Berlin zu Diana
Zimmermann Diana ein richtiges Kanzler
Machtwort also gerade nicht zu hören
aber sein Regierungssprecher sagt die
Beschlüsse stehen ist es mehr als eine
Beschwichtigung ja das ist vermutlich
der Versuch der Sprachrohr des Kanzlers
zu sein allerdings funktioniert legieren
bei machtworten nicht besonders gut zu
viel Schaden ist auch schon wieder
angerichtet als als dass ein solches
Machtwort funktionieren könnte sehr
abrupte Entscheidungen etwa bei den
E-Autos zu wenig Kommunikation und dann
wiederum viel zu viel Gerede das ganze
deutet darauf hin dass die Ampel eben
nicht in der Lage ist einen einmal
gefassten Beschluss über mehrere Tage
nach außen durchzuhalten und das kreiert
natürlich eine unglaubliche Unsicherheit
in der Bevölkerung es kreiert auch sehr
viel viel Unzufriedenheit in den
Parteien wir haben uns heute da umgehört
und da ist sehr viel Frust und
Enttäuschung darüber dass jetzt dieser
so mühsam gewonnene Kompromiss schon
wieder zerredet wird dass die Ampel
schon wieder ein solches Bild der
Zerstrittenheit abgibt und es mischt
sich darin auch noch etwas anderes und
das ist große Sorge Sorge darüber dass
die AFD die Unsicherheit die die
ampelregierung sätt ernten könnte
nächstes Jahr stehen Europawahlen an und
drei Landtagswahlen danke nach Berlin
Diana zimmermann
wegen der Verbreitung von
Falschinformationen hat die
EU-Kommission ein Verfahren gegen den
onlineedienst Ex ehmals Twitter eröffnet
es werde geprüft ob Ex gegen EU-Regeln
zur Verbreitung illegaler Inhalte
verstößt und ob die Plattform
entschieden genug gegen Hassrede vorgeht
brüssel hatte Ex bereits zuvor wegen
irreführender Beiträge über den Krieg im
gasstreifen verwarnt und da gibt es nach
Medienberichten neue Verhandlungen über
die Freilassung von Geiseln laut
israelischer Zeitung Harz verhandeln
darüber die Geheimdienstchefs Israels
und der USA mit dem katarischen
Ministerpräsidenten gleichzeitig steigt
der Druck auf Israel wegen der großen
Anzahl ziviler Opfer im Gazastreifen das
militärische Vorgehen zu ändern
Henriette demesia
berichtet das Kamal Advan Krankenhaus im
Norden des Gazastreifens Bilder der
Zerstörung nach einem israelischen
Luftangriff vergangene Woche das
Krankenhaus nicht mehr einsatzfähig
mindestens acht Patienten seinen ums
Leben gekommen der Chef der WHO gibrieus
äußerte sich gestern auf dem
kurzbotschaftendienst X entsetzt über
die faktische Zerstörung des kamaladwan
Krankenhauses Gazas Gesundheitssystem
sei ohnehin schon am Limit er forderte
eine Waffenpause das israelische Militär
veröffentlicht diese Bilder aus dem
Krankenhaus Waffenfunde in Wärmebettchen
für Babys Gewehre Handgranaten Kriegs
Waffen in einem Schutzort um die
Verhältnismäßigkeit dieses Krieges geht
es auch bei den Gesprächen mit
usverteidigungsminister Austin der heute
in Israel eintraf ich bin auch hier um
darüber zu sprechen wie wir Israel am
besten unterstützen können seine
dauerhafte Sicherheit zu gewährleisten
es braucht aber auch mehr humanitäre
Unterstützung für die beinah 2 Millionen
Vertriebenen in Gaza und wir müssen
diese Hilfe besser
verteilen vorsichtig kritische Töne des
wichtigsten Verbündeten
Israels ich habe nochmals bekräftigt
unsere Verpflichtung ist der totale Sieg
über die Hamas und ich denke es ist
nicht nur unser Krieg sondern auch ihr
Krieg denn sie sind die Führer der
zivilisierten
Welt es scheinen keine ganz einfachen
Gespräche und die internationale Kritik
an Israel sie wird
größer nach dem russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine hat sich Deutschland
verplicht sich noch stärker in der NATO
zu engagieren besonders im Baltikum
genauer in litaauen das Land liegt an
der NATO ostlanke grenzt an Belarus und
das russische Kaliningrad Deutschland
will bis 2027 in Litauen eine
einsatzbereite Brigade stationieren das
heißt vor Ort müssen Quartiere und
Versorgung für rund 5000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten organisiert werden eine
entsprechende Vereinbarung
unterzeichnete Minister Pistorius jetzt
in vilnis Ines trums die Koordination
der Flaggen Haut noch nicht hin aber
ansonsten sind sie sich einig eine
deutsche kampfbrigade dauerhaft in
Litauen stationiert
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat sie
nun seinem litaauischen Amtskollegen
zugesagt dieses Projekt ist ein
Leuchtturmprojekt der Zeitenwende das
Tempo in dem wir vorgehen macht deutlich
wir haben in Deutschland die
sicherheitspolitischen Realitäten
verstanden und wir senden ein klares
Zeichen auch an alle die Frieden und
sicher Frieden und Sicherheit in Europa
bedrohen könnten Weihnachtsbesuch bei
den deutschen Soldaten die bereits heute
im Rahmen einer natoinsatztruppe in
Litauen sind künftig sollen 4800 mit
ihren Familien hier leben es gilt die
Ostflanke vor einem Überraschungsangriff
zu sichern wir machen uns auch nicht
tagtäglich so ein Kopf darüber wie nah
wir dem Krieg sind wir mürden uns
dadurch
nur verrückt machen sage ich jetzt mal
wir sind uns natürlich bewusst der
Bundeswehr fehlt es an Gerät und
Personal doch diese Brigade soll nun
gestemmt werden hier ist es ernst ja
hier muss man sich vorbereiten durch
glaubwürdige Abschreckung und
verteidigungsfähig sein wenn etwas
passiert und deswegen hat das oberste
Priorität und andere Dinge müssen dann
gegebenenfalls dahinter zurückstehen
eine dauerhaft stationierte Brigade an
der Ostflanke mit dieser Zusage hat
Minister Pistorius die Truppe und auch
sich selbst unter Druck gesetzt ein
Kraftakt unklar ob er gelingt Pistorius
ist optimistisch dass die Soldaten
freiwillig nach Litauen umsiedeln für
die ersten Posten gab es viermal so
viele Bewerbungen wie
nötig eine wichtige Nachricht für Eltern
sie können sich seit heute telefonisch
vom Arzt bescheinigen lassen dass sie
ihr krankes Kind betreuen müssen ein
Besuch in der Praxis ist nicht mehr
nötig wenn der Arzt das Kind kennt für
kranke Kinder bis 12 Jahren können sich
maximal 5 Tage von der Arbeit
freistellen
lassen und Rom bewegt sich doch könnte
man sagen der Papst hat den Weg für die
Segnung homosexueller Paare freigemacht
unter bestimmten Bedingungen das geht
aus einem Schreiben des Vatikans hervor
niemand dürfe vom Segen ausgeschlossen
werden aber es dürfe auch keine
Verwechslung mit dem Ehesakrament geben
in Deutschland werden bereits
segensfeiern für homosexuelle Paare wie
hier in Köln praktiziert sie finden aber
bis ja in einer kirchenrechtlichen
Grauzone
statt unser Experte für die katholische
Kirche heißt Jürgen Erbacher ist jetzt
im Studio Herr Erbacher erstmal guten
Abend wie würden Sie diesen Schritt
bezeichnen ist das eine kehtwende des
Vatikans ja noch vor zwei Jahren hat der
Vatikan gesagt dass eine Segnung
gleichgeschlechtlicher Paare nicht
erlaubt ist jetzt die
180°wende die ganz auf der Linie von
Papst franziskus liegt der eben sagt
wenn ein paar die Hilfe Gottes für seine
Beziehung will dann können wir die nicht
verwehren das steht allerdings in einem
Widerspruch zur traditionellen Lehre zu
Ehe und Homosexualität und hier versucht
der Vatikan mit diesem Papier jetzt so
einen ersten Schritt mit der
Fokussierung auf die Seelsorge dass man
diese Spannung auflöst allerdings ganz
gelingt es am Ende nicht ist denn dieser
Schritt des Vatikans jetzt mit
Einschränkungen verbunden ja der Vatikan
sagt viele aber man darf es nicht
verwechseln mit der traditionellen
Eheschließung man darf es z.B auch nicht
im Zusammenhang mit der standesamtlichen
Feier von gleichgeschlechtlichen pa
machen da werden viele Betroffene sagen
das ist ein Segen zweiter Klasse aber es
ist ein erster Schritt hier wurde eine
Tür aufgestoßen die lange Jahre
verschlossen war und die
Kirchengeschichte zeigt eine veränderte
Praxis führt oft auch am Ende zu einer
Veränderung der Lehre herrbacher vielen
Dank für die Einordnung
bitteschön wir schauen jetzt nach
Serbien wo die rechtsnationale Partei
von Präsident wuic die vorgezogene
Parlamentswahl mit 47% der Stimmen
deutlich gewonnen hat damit kann die
serbische Fortschrittspartei allein
regieren trotz hoher Inflation
monatelanger Proteste gegen die
Regierung und Korruptionsvorwürfen
überschattet wurde die Wahl von
Betrugsvorwürfen die Opposition spricht
von zahlreichen Unregelmäßigkeiten und
Stimmenkauf im Kampf gegen Corona und
andere Krankheiten hat Außenministerin
berbock afrikanischen Staaten die
Unterstützung Deutschlands zugesagt
Krankheiten kennen keine Ländergrenzen
und unsere Solidarität darf es auch
nicht sagte sie bei ihrem Treffen mit
dem Außenminister randas in der
Hauptstadt Kigali wbock besucht dort
eine Baustelle des Pharmaunternehmens
biontech für die erste kommerzielle mRNA
impfstoffabrik auf afrikanischem
Boden jetzt zu einem Ärgernis für jeden
Autofahrer und eine Herausforderung auch
für die Politik die marode
brückeninrastruktur in Deutschland
allein an Autobahnen sind vier 000
Brücken so kaputt dass sie modernisiert
oder neu gebaut werden müssen aktuell
sind rund 1300 in Bearbeitung gerade
fertig wurde die salzbachtalbrücke an
der A66 in Hessen am Wochenende gab's
die öffentliche Erstbegehung seit dem
Nachmittag darf endlich auch wieder
gefahren werden Markus
wollseffer es ist ein dankbarer Termin
für den Verkehrsminister um 15:30 Uhr
schneidet Volker Wissing das Band durch
er gibt die salzbachilbrücke für den
verkehrfrei eine gute Nachricht für
Wiesbaden und das ganze
rheinminebiet die Autobahn sind unsere
Lebensadern s notwendig für die
Wirtschaft und natürlich auch für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger doch der Minister
weiß auch es liegt einiges im agen die
salzbachtalbrücke ist kein Einzelfall
eher das Symptom einer insgesamt maroden
Infrastruktur Beispiele gibt es viele
wie die Leverkusener reheinbrücke
somarode dass sie für den
Schwerlastverkehr gesperrt werden musste
Dauerstress für Pendler große Einbußen
für die chaft oder die ramedetilbrücke
auf der A45 die Sauerlandlinie eine
wichtige Achse vom Ruhrgebiet in den
Süden auch diese Brücke musste gesperrt
und später gesprengt werden Lüdenscheid
erstickt seitdem im Umleitungsverkehr
die Gründe für die Misere vielfältig zu
wenig Investitionen zu viel Bürokratie
und lange
Planungsverfahren was eigentlich das
Problem ist ist die Regulierungswut
Planfeststellung Linienbestimmung
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung und diese
Anforderungen werden ständig verschärft
von der Politik der stat habe so die
Kritik zu lange zu wenig gemacht häufig
von der Substanz gelebt mit dem
genehmigungsbeschleunigungsgesetz will
die Bundesregierung nun gegensteuern das
Ziel schneller planen und bauen das
scheint dringend nötig eine Brücke zu
sanieren oder auszubauen bisher dauert
das in Deutschland 5 bis 18
Jahre und wir bauen jetzt eine Brücke
zum Sport in der Fußball Champions
League weiß man jetzt wie es weitergt im
Februar wird wieder gespielt noch drei
deutsche Vereine sind ja im Achtelfinale
der Königsklasse dabei und die Auslosung
in neon Schweiz ergab zwei durchaus
lösbare Aufgaben und ein sogenanntes
Hammerlos denn Erb Leipzig trifft
zunächst zu Hause auf den Rekordgewinner
der Champions League Real Madrid der FC
Bayern München muss zuerst auswärts ran
bei Lazio Rom der in der italienischen
Liga arg schwächelt und Borussia
Dortmund beim PSW enthofen dem
souveränen ligaspitzenreiter der
Niederlande in der Bundesliga halten die
Bayern Anschluss an Tabellenführer Bayer
Leverkusen im Verfolgerduell gegen den
VfB Stuttgart traff zweimal Harry Kane
für den Rekordmeister wovor Kim den 30
Endstand erzielte alle Höhepunkte des 15
Spieltages bei uns im Internet unter
zdfheute.de und in der ZDF heute
App ja der Höhepunkt zum Ende des
Sportjahres die Wahl Sportler Sportlerin
und Mannschaft des Jahres in Baden-Baden
eine glanzvolle Gala mit Liebe und guter
Laune der Lohn beim des deutschen Sports
und in Marotten von lasas dause als
turnweltmeister und dann stehe ich
eigentlich mal auf meine Badelatschen
die liegen eigentlich hier parallel vom
Bett dann schlupfe ich da so rein zieh
mir die so bisschen über die Füße und
dann okay und nicht me im falschen Fuß
Aufstehen genau und er ist recht nicht
als Sportler des Jahres geehrt von
seiner Frau du hast vor ein paar Monaten
den Barren in anwerpben vergoldet und
ich hoffe ich kann dir heute Abend den
Abend in ben Baden vergolden ihr Ego
hinten angestellt dann WM Gold für die
deutschen Basketballspieler was für eine
sympathiewahl haben Lust dass Basketball
ansteckend ist d dass viele Kinder den
Sport spielen den wir lieben und
Sportlerin des Jahres Denise Hermann
Wick mit dem umschwärmten Laudator dem
Bergdoktor
wel der Sportler des Jahres die Siegerin
hat schon aufgehört der Sport dagegen
geht weiter
2024 in ein
suersportjahr Handball Fußball EM
Olympia Paras mega schick schick danke
schön Christin ja nicht sportlich aber
außergewöhnlich kreativ ist die Leistung
eines thailändischen reißbauern denn mit
Hilfe verschiedenfarbiger reissßorten
ist diese Plantage zu einer gigantischen
cartoonkatze herangereift ein
ausgeklügeltes System steckt dahinter
jeder reietzling wurde nämlich nach
Geodaten per Hand gesetzt zu bestauen
ist das Kunstwerk aber nur für wenige
Wochen kein Wetter zum Reisanbau bei uns
da gibt's kühle Temperaturen Regen und
Sturm mehr dazu gleich von östen terli
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius ab 21:45
Uhr im heute journal Interview mit Dunja
Hayali schönen Dank fürs Interesse
schönen Abend und bis
[Musik]
morgen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein neues Tief
zieht auf und bringt uns morgen
kräftigen Regen hier mit dieser
Kaltfront was sie aber noch sehen ist
eine satte nordwestliche Strömung die
sich hinter diesem Tief hier etablieren
wird und in den nächsten Tagen gibt's
eine satte sturmlage mit teils Sturm und
orkanböhnen ab Donnerstag wir schauen
aber erstmal auf die kommende Nacht und
da gibt's im Norden Regen nach Süden
lockert zunehmend auf an der Donau da
bildet sich Nebel und im Süden ist es
dann größtenteils frostig bis -5° 5°
plus gibt's in den höheren Lagen und
auch pluswerte ganz im Norden mit 8° z.B
in Schleswig-Holstein morgen dann regen
der Richtung Mitte schwinkt und im Süden
ja an der Donau hier hält sich der Nebel
und da wird es höchstens 0° maximal
geben 11° an den Alpen mit viel
Sonnenschein und 9° ganz im Norden und
die nächsten Tage richtig windig wird es
Mittwoch nimmt der Wind schon mal zu bei
3 bis 8 gr Donnerstag dann die sturmlage
und vor allem die Nacht von Donnerstag
auf Freitag wird sehr windig werden und
damit einen schönen Abend